hi woody how are you my friends all said
that the Sun would come up this morning
they're wrong and he's not yet
what if Denver won that game last night
what would we be talking about that
the Chiefs worked and Pat mahomes wasn't
as good as advertised and that there was
a wide-open AFC West and the Broncos
were back I mean in case keenum makes
that connection with Demaryius Thomas
and we're talking about we're talking
about that today right that was
horrendous he was wide open for the
touchdown they would have won and as a
result instead people today are talking
about clock that ran out clock ran out
on the Chiefs but time ran out on de
barcos it's just a continuation of
what's been going on here since Super
Bowl 50 that the Broncos have fallen
from grace with the sea and it's a
difficult situation and people are in
mourning not for the Broncos and Iraqis
but they're in mourning for pretty
because it ruined his life last night
the Broncos found their quarterback
though do you think Case Keenum is is
the quarterback in retrospect they
should have gone after one of those
young quarterbacks and that was the
opportunity and that's what John Elway
debated and privately he really wanted
to get young quarterback he wanders
interested in Kirk Cousins as people
believed but don't like you had to act
on a veteran quarterback because it
worked so well as you know with Peyton
Manning now Case Keenum never will be
Peyton Manning but they felt like they
were close enough that if they got a
veteran quarterback who had a great year
last year with the Vikings that it would
it would make a significant difference
and really case came and played a good
game so far and the first four they're
lucky actually given everything that
they're two and two at this point they
could have lost to the Raiders and they
were in behind and in a opening game to
the Seahawks in the fourth quarter
I guess if you were to go back and you
now look at the production of the of the
four quarterbacks that were there Baker
Mayfield was they they saw him play like
15 different times and met coach Newman
in the Senior Bowl and they really
wanted wanted him but I think there was
fear about a six-foot quarterback and
whether he was another Johnny Manziel
and they ended up getting a 6-foot
quarterback and Casey and him the first
glance in person I'm guessing at Patrick
mahomes what did you think I haven't
seen anybody throw a wobbly left-handed
pass since Tim Tebow left here but he's
as advertised
I'd city played to earlier times on TV
but seeing in person he's very mature
and I think he has all the ingredients
to me with the talent he's surrounded by
the Broncos did their best put pressure
on him and they didn't play glove on him
all night so I think that that the
debate continues between mahomes and
nail to Biscay is entered into the
conversation in regard to you know who's
the best of the younger quarterbacks
because one been here for a while but I
I think Holmes is was worth what Kansas
City did last year to get him and this
is a quarterback a guy was telling me on
the elevator yesterday said Lenny Dawson
and I looked at it that's all he said to
be linear and I said what do you mean
you said that's the last time we've had
a quarterback and I said said luck but
it eats ahead who who is said like
that's last time the Chicago Bears that
of course Lenny don't yeah I'm trying to
think who else Kansas City had well Alex
Smith I think was a better than average
quarterback I just well he was talking
about somebody they developed from the
very beginning okay you know as you
remember Joe Montana had a nice run
there during I remember him beating John
Elway you know Monday night game here so
they had Montana for a while but on that
they've had such a string
like Cleveland Browns they had they had
not had a drafted quarterback for like
20-something years I think so that's
what they're taught about to pay the
last time they had a quarterback was in
Dawson that took them to the Super Bowl
he's what he paid starve around the horn
Denver columnist joining us Dan Patrick
show I'm curious if you've ever done
this woody guy I asked Dan Shaughnessy
about this if you've ever published
columns that you wrote during a game and
then all of a sudden you had like a
different ending but what you would have
written what you were writing at the
time if you if you release that column
what would it have said have you ever
gone back and looked at that where all
of a sudden you go I got to change the
entire column that I just wrote oh I
would guess probably 30 times during the
NBA playoffs world series but I'll tell
you the best and the worst was the
Dodgers played in in Denver
no 1995-97 something like that and the
game was delayed because of rain and
didn't start till about 8:30 and I wrote
a column saying the Dodgers were not and
were not any good terrible team not good
pitching just had no chance of winning
the World Series and I wrote that about
the sixth inning
a guy named Nomo was pitching a
no-hitter and so I said well maybe you
need to rethink that column and I said
well there's no way anybody's ever going
to pitch a no-hitter in vivir Colorado
it just will happen all the games were
16 to 14 and he went on the controller
middle hitter and so I was rewriting the
column and I called the newspaper and I
said well I got a new column on the
no-hitter and they said our deadlines
passed the papers are being printed and
it was the only time in my life that I
prayed for a blizzard of the century and
I got so many responses that was really
in the birth of the internet but I got
so many phone calls the jam the the
system in Denver and saying you know at
least you could have said that even
though the pitching is bad for the
Dodgers
normal pitch a no-hitter lies yes it is
it is a rare but it's one of those times
when you want to get the car go around
try and pick up every newspaper how do
you feel about the rock it has the
Rockies mindset because it used to be
that slugfest softball like scores there
why don't we why don't we have that flow
of offense like we once had in Colorado
the humidor really changed I think not
only Denver but I know the Diamondbacks
have have installed a humidor because
they're the second highest elevation
right and and nobody talks about the
Arizona Diamondbacks in their stats but
we always talk about the Rockies well as
they usually were to get but it started
the fourth quarter last night the the
Broncos have a video they play about
showing Aspen and the mountains and one
mile above sea level and there's no
other team and in football it has that
and there was a great moment where they
then show one of the Kansas City Chiefs
on the sidelines sucking up oxygen and
because of the altitude and I've talked
a number of former major league pitchers
it's not so much the height but the lack
of humidity here Dan and you can't get a
good grip on the ball and obviously in
thin air and it's been proven
scientifically I know that doesn't
doesn't ring true with a lot of people
in government but the altitude does and
the climate here does change the flight
of the ball and so guys who can break
off a great curve ball at sea-level
can't do it at altitude and so
everything comes in flat and as I said 1
1 pitch Kobe you never can get a good
feel on the baseball because it's so dry
the humidor kind of changed that but I
think what changed it more is that and
I'll give you a prime example Kyle
Freeland should be in the side yard
conversation and nobody
talk to him talk about him too late and
he's won 17 games Cal Friedland grew up
in altitude and maybe their mistake has
been not drafted who grew up to call up
or in other nearby states because he
didn't care I mean he's told me he
doesn't care about the house - he said
it's always been this way but they have
drafted and and signed as undrafted free
agents from Latino countries who don't
care about the attitude altitude or the
attitude here and they also for the
first time rather than getting washed up
pictures from other clubs because as you
well know most veteran pitchers want no
part of pitching in Colorado eaters a
business team or certainly not as a home
team and so I think the mindset changed
the philosophy changed when they started
just drafting picture after picture who
they thought could pitch keep the ball
down that altitude have you ever come
close to wanting to punch somebody on
around the horn even though you're not
together but if you were together who
would have got popped
okay Mariotti said but I don't know what
I could say this or the radio but it's
the funny story behind-the-scenes story
at the retina Horne was I always called
him Richard and he would call ESPN
executives every day every day he called
him and he and Jim Cohen who is now with
the NFL Network was a good friend of
mine he's a vice president and he
finally called me and he said Jay
Mariotti complains that you can't get
his name right you can't keep calling
Richard I said well I can't call him
dick I swear this true story so he said
you can't do that anymore
no he's being ruled that I couldn't call
him Richard anymore so the next day I
called him Jim and Jim Cohen called me
said
why are you calling
Mariotti gym now and I said because your
dick I hope reality gives you some bonus
points for this woody no he he he
doesn't like my old time references
yesterday I said that our world our
Ryder Cup team was so bad but then we
haven't won anything in France since a
year before I was born
and reality said what happened then and
I said World War two you won this shows
yeah you just puts up with me yeah it's
a big day in Denver the Rockies and the
Broncos needed to win because I'd
already won and some guy wrote me said
what do you win that really weird good
to visit with you here in Detroit they
had a Superbowl using 15 20 years ago I
was walking through the conference
center though Chevrolet conference
center and I heard someone say my name
and I turned to you and you were on the
air and you said welcome to the dark
side
so thank you for this and and you
haven't left you've you've made it your
home what do what woody hey great to
talk to you again and have fun with the
Rockies and the Cubs thank you yeah take
care of Fritzi today all right we will
we will
Thank You woody woody pay around the
horn I like when somebody says I don't
know if I'm allowed to say this on the
radio and then that's when you go I'm
not gonna say a word here that's funny
that's a funny J Mariotti story for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you